we've seen jason bateman grow from that  little kid in silver spoons  to that funny brother in the hogan  family that everyone adored to the money  laundering father marty bird in ozark  his on-screen wife wendy played by laura  linney was a couple years behind him  entering the scene with a steep climb to  critical success in the 90s she played  the right moves to land the leading role  in many award-winning films down the  ladder comes julia garner who plays the  hot tempered ruth she became popular a  few years before ozark starring in  dramatic indie films and blockbuster  hits  she was destined to be an ozarkian if  you watched daredevil you'll be able to  spot skyler gottner before his famous  jonah bird sophia hublitz was a chef  reality tv chef turned actor we're not  really sure how this happened but we're  glad we got this one playing charlotte